e
to call the public works and highways to
order uh our first bill today uh is
house bill number
561 relative to the transfer of
state-owned real property and
municipality
please good morning Mr chair and
honorable committee members I'm
representative Nancy Murphy serving my
third term representing the wonderful
people of Mayor Mack Hillsboro 12 I'm
happy to be here this morning to
introduce HB 561 a bill meant to protect
all New Hampshire municipalities that
could find themselves on the receiving
end of State Highway property for which
they neither wish to take responsibility
nor can afford to maintain and
repair HB 561 would amend sections of
RSA 230 colon 57 RSA 4 colon 39 and RSA
for colon 40 relative to discontinuance
of relocated portions of class one and
to highways reversion to town disposal
of Highway federal or Turnpike funded
real
estate bulk disposal of highway or
Turnpike funded real estate and disposal
of state-owned real estate HB 561 has
been filed to protect municipalities
from State action that would impose an
unfunded mandate upon them by way of
discontinuing reclassifying or reverting
New Hampshire's highways to the towns in
which they are located
despite opposition from local governing
bodies on behalf of their
residents should such actions by the
state ever be allowed and undertaken an
undue and disproportionate potential
budget crippling burden would be placed
upon impacted New Hampshire's towns and
cities while those from outside the town
or city that utilize the highway escape
the financial burden associated with
Highway maintenance and repair costs
this is
unjust not only is it unjust it is a
clear violation of part one Bill of
Rights of the New Hampshire State
Constitution Article
28a the state shall not mandate or
assign any new expanded or modified
programs or responsibility to any public
subdivision political subdivision in
such a way as to necessitate additional
local expenditures by the political
subdivision unless such programs or
responsibilities are fully funded by the
state
or unless such programs or
responsibilities are approved for
funding by a vote of the local
legislative body of the political
subdivision while New Hampshire citizens
and those of us elected to represent
them recognize the need to address
Revenue short shortfalls and move
forward with fiscally constrained
budgets an unfunded mandate which would
Target citizen taxpayers in a given
municipality is neither just nor
Equitable solution to the larger budget
issue Granite Staters have reached their
maximum ability to absorb any additional
cost downshifted from state government
frankly they've had it citizens are
paying attention and recognize that the
school and Municipal portions of the
property tax bills they receive that
come due every June and December are
increasing because the state is
downshifting Municipal and education
cost to property
taxpayers this compounds the unavoidable
increases local school districts and
municipalities have to include for cost
of living adjustments Rising health
insurance costs and benefits contractual
obligations and costs already
downshifted from the state to
municipalities for things like the New
Hampshire retirement system citizens
have to live within a budget and do not
have the luxury of being able to
downshift their cost to anyone else any
attempt by the state of New Hampshire to
discontinue reclassify or revert New
Hampshire's highways to the towns in
which they are located is another
example of the State trying to pass the
buck or should I say pass the bill for
its responsibilities to municipalities
and their citizens it is time for those
in state government to realize that its
budget decisions to date have created a
situation whereby property tax burdens
have surpassed citizens ability to pay
and residents cannot bear a single other
increase to their property tax bills
across this entire state overburdened
couples young families senior citizens
single parents and firsttime home buyers
are receiving property tax bills they
simply cannot afford HB 561 aims to
prevent the setting of a dangerous
precedent that could at any time impact
any town in New Hampshire including the
ones that each of you
represent if the state feeling an EP an
economic pinch and revenues are short
should suddenly decide to unload
responsibility for its Highway property
on to a municipality at will even if the
local select board or Town Council
opposes such action on behalf of
impacted taxpayers discontinuing
reclassifying or reverting state-owned
highways to the town or city in which it
is located solves a problem for the
state but creates a much larger problem
for
municipality what kind of slippery slope
would that be and what would be next as
it is our duty and obligation to
advocate for the best interests of the
citizens we represent we must protect
New Hampshire property taxpayers from
being forced to take on and bear the
overly burdensome cost in liabilities
for State highways that rightfully
belong to and should be managed by their
owner the state of New Hampshire passing
HB 561 will protect the rights of
impacted municipalities to re refuse
receivership of state owned highways and
protect New Hampshire taxpayers from the
inequitable and unfair property tax
burden that would result if that were to
happen despite the disapproval I
respectfully request your support for HB
561 and would appreciate an OTP
recommendation thank you for your time
and consideration and I have copies of
questions seeing none I'd like to
recognize representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh for the record I'm uh my
name is Wendy Thomas and I represent the
town of marac um a state road by
definition is used by everyone it's not
used by just people in the town however
allocating the state road to the town
makes the town responsible for all of
the costs uh representative Murphy did a
good job of explaining the problem um
all I will say is that disposing of
state roads will have a huge impact to
our town as this would be a huge impact
to any town please know that it's
threatening us today and it could happen
to your District tomorrow that's all I
have to say thank you thank you any
much like to recognize rosem Roy please
rung thank you very much Mr chair for
the record my name is rosem Marie rang
and I'm a representative of Hillsboro 12
um I want to kind of remind those of you
who are in uh not in your freshman year
but uh if you were here last year the um
the house the Senate and the governor
signed into law it was um Senate Bill
539 and I want to read part of that bill
because it um already establishes a
president for requiring a governing a
governing body to approve transfer of
Assets in this bill it says upon notice
by the department the governing body
shall cause the legislative body to
answer the question of whether the
legislative body wants to accept the
transfer of ownership of the dam at the
same meeting the legislative body shall
consider the issuance of any long-term
debt necessary to effectuate the
transfer and address any deficiencies if
the legislative body votes to accept the
transfer but denies issuance of the debt
the department shall consider that to be
a rejection of the offer so we've
already approved in this state a process
for transferring State assets in Senate
Bill 539 it has to do with a a dam but
this bill has to do with roads and it
for the same reasons that this bill was
passed we need to pass um I mean the
same reasons that Senate Bill 539 was
passed we have to pass this bill because
as was previous previously
stated no town or city in this state
should have to assume a tremendous cost
for something that provides value to the
entire state so um I'd like you to
consider an TP motion on this bill and
again if you want to read what we've
already done please uh check out Senate
Bill 539 um it was sponsored by Senator
Keith Murphy co-sponsored by Senator
Bradley Senator birdell Senator
dallesandro Senator Carson Senator Aus
Senator Waters Senator Pearl um
representative Osborne representative
Alexander representative Missour and
representative Carol Maguire so thank
you very much I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you thank you uh
representative cludia please okay thank
you Mr chair Rose uh representative rung
could you tell me the year that this
bill was passed and became law um it was
passed this in 2024 20 all right 2024
May SEC uh May 2nd 2024 May 2nd okay I
will look that up thank you thank you Mr
but the language the language is there
and it's very clear the intent is the
same as this this
bill you any other questions seeing none
thank you thank UHD like to
works please put your mic on please
should know better um I'm uh currently
chairman of the marac Town Council and
I'm here this morning just to elucidate
what we've had to uh deal with uh with
um the downshifting of the section of
high state owned roadway called
Continental Boulevard in our town um a
few years ago there was uh um amendments
to legislation to add this uh release of
this road to marac and it was in gu to
save money for the State of New
Hampshire which I appreciate that desire
but it becomes a downshifting situation
uh the segment that the state owns is
about two miles long and the cost to
maintain that roadway All Things
Considered um would be costing the town
of marac about
$500,000 a year um we we didn't like
that the what uh we will be receiving
this road in four more years I believe
it was 2029 they did pass it this past
year as an amendment to to the uh
um I believe was part of the budget but
uh the only the good good thing for
marac is that this is a road that serves
as a u a release for r 101a that travels
uh from Route 101 and I believe it's
Milford to nashwa and 101a is was very
congested when they built a Continental
Boulevard um Exit 8 had been constructed
to relieve the traffic on 101a and
Continental Boulevard was for the same
reason the only good thing for marac is
that when this does become our road we
can shut it down and that difficulty for
the town city of Nashville will be great
and I believe it will be taken back by
the state if not sooner it's a road that
is a Causeway that gets people from 101a
to the ever Turnpike and I'm asking you
to support this legislation thank you
thank you sir any
mcau welcome to public
works good morning Mr chairman honorable
board members thank you for letting me
speak to House Bill 561 while I'm here
as the town manager of merac I believe
that this bill will affect the entire
State as a community who is going to be
given New Hampshire dot maintain Road in
the future I do not want to see this
happen to any other community in the
state currently to repave Continental
Boulevard just that 2 Mile Stretch dot
million the fiscal impacts that this
will have on the town is anywhere
between 2 cents New Hampshire dot uh
estimates versus our 10-cent estimate of
$500,000 like like the state the town is
struggling with budget we know that as
difficult decisions as it relates to
Public Safety roads and bridges solid
waste and the general needs versus wants
of a
community I am sure I am not the only
Community dealing with these issues
however even a two-cent increase to some
of our residents is too much you will
see support from the bill from a number
of my colleagues who could not be here
today please do not let this happen to
any other community it already happened
to Newington and now marac and it's a
troubling precedent that is being set
that nhdot can just reclassify a road
and give it to a
community I do want to leave you with
final thoughts I want you to imagine
that if there's roads in your state that
New Hampshire do or your town or
community that New Hampshire do
maintains if they just reclassified it
to your community what will that do what
will that do to the constituents in your
party in your in your area once again I
consideration thank you sir is there any
questions yes representative jurus thank
you Mr chairman thank you for being here
today in the uh in the turnover to the
from the from the state DOT to the town
of meramac in that agreement is the
state not is the state going to repave
that section of Continental Boulevard we
have no details of what the state plans
to do or not do in that section this was
a committee of conference that came up
with this decision um it was uh run
through boards um the committee of
conference came up in the last minute um
one of the uh state senators came up
with this consideration and it was
accepted by the committee of conference
uh we do not have any details of what
dot plans to do in that area I do know
that there are several culverts that
probably need to be be replaced there
are three or four traffic lights in that
area that are getting old in the tooth
one of them's been updated the other two
have not it's a two mile section of Road
um there
are uh very few if any opportunities on
that road considering uh and through
that road section there is a penchuk
Waterworks which is n Nash's water
supply that owns several acres of land
uh Fidelity Investments own several
acres of land so there is no
development uh in that area that
potentially can go on be in that Two
Mile Stretch for the town to help offset
the cost and unless penchuk sells their
property or Fidelity sells some of their
land which I do not see happening in the
near
future okay one more real I'll please
thank you Mr chairman and thanks again
and the state the the the turnpike
remove the tolls uh from that area what
10 years ago to relieve citizens of
maramag correct uh I don't believe it
was 10 years ago it was it was it was
several years ago but I don't know if it
was 10 years I don't not have the exact
date
okay um thank you thank you any further
questions saying none Mr chair I'm sorry
representative cler thank you very much
uh you referred to something the town of
Newington and another Community where
the dot basically forced the communities
to accept the reclassified what was the
other community it's marac and Newington
marac and okay all right Newton do you
remember Newington when that happened I
could always ask doot but was curious um
I believe that
happened in the early 2000s 2010 um my
colleague uh um did mention it and there
was uh some back and forth uh they hire
Consultants to do studies and there was
an agreement um that happened between
the state and uh Newton where they
replaced and repaved and did a bunch of
other things to get the road back but
like I said earlier that uh there was
none of that discussion with the town of
marac they're just giving us the road
okay all right thank you very much
you I'd like to rec recognize Steve
lebante
please welcome to Public Works Mr
lebante thank you Mr chairman um as
you've just heard I'm Steve Leon I'm
with the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation I uh currently serve as
the legislative liaison some of you may
remember my predecessor Kathy M hampson
prior to this I served for seven years
in the Bureau of right of way uh I have
my colleague Eric Sergeant here who is
now the current administrator of right
of way I am the former administrator of
right of way and the Bureau of right of
way is really it's the real estate
section of the Department of
Transportation we're responsible for
acquiring property
for Highway projects we're also
responsible for doing um disposal of
surplus property and also we do we do
discontinuance of Highway RightWay when
necessary and we do play a role in
reclassifying um reclassifying highways
from a class one or two to a class five
when it's
appropriate um so one thing I want to
point out is is with the bill it talks
about and and we don't we're here to
provide background information as to how
the department uses the statutes that
are being proposed to be
amended one thing I will say is highways
do not um highways that are in active
use are not Surplus property so we
wouldn't be disposing of them under 4
colon 39c for colon
39f or 440 because if it's an active use
it can't be
Surplus so what we would do in a
situation like that if it were deemed um
to be so if if the highway section
wasn't being used anymore we might
consider doing a discontinuance under
RSA 230 colon uh 55 through um colon 62
and what happens with the
discontinuance most of the time and and
in my time at Right Way
um it's usually done when a project will
move an
intersection and
then the old roaded doesn't just go away
it has to actually be formally
discontinued because it was laid out by
a governmental entity and then it has to
be discontinued through that process so
the commissioner May identify that often
times what happens like happened in
barington is a property owner will come
to us because they bought a piece of
property project happened 40 years ago
so there's no more asphalt there there's
trees growing out of it but when they
went to get their their permitting they
realized that there's a highway that
runs right across the where their
proposed front lawn's going to be so
they'll approach the department this
happened at the intersection of Route
202 and 126 in barington um where we had
a former project many years ago but that
section never got discontinued so we
went through the discontinuing process
for this property owner that is how a a
um a discontinuance typically Works in
that process we approach the T we have
to notify the town the town has 60 days
to act and then if they if the town does
nothing that section automatically
reverts back reverts to the town but if
uh if they do they hold a hearing they
find that there that that section of
Road cannot be used for municipal
Highway purposes so then we go through
the process um of doing that and I will
point out the statutory scheme provides
for uh a um damaged property owner to
bring a claim against the department for
damages so that's typically how that
works um so then we get into reclass
ification now I from the testimony I
heard and I I'll admit I'm not all that
familiar with Continental bulevard uh
with marac but what I heard from the
testimony today that wasn't done by the
commissioner of
transportation that was done as a as an
um as an act of legislation so I'm I'm
not sure the background there typically
a good example of
reclassification is Enterprise Drive in
Windom if you're traveling south on 9 93
and you see you're at Exit 3 you see
kind of a large clock tower there that's
the end of Enterprise Drive that was
formerly Route
111 uh back before we went in there and
reconstructed that but after we bypass
that section of Route 111 it serves just
a local population so it takes on the
character of a local Road um and um so
that in that case that was reclassified
to a class five highway now the town of
Windam maintains it uh I will say there
was some discussion earlier about an
unfunded
mandate the town of Nelson case uh the
Supreme Court ruled on that and found
and and determined that it it is not an
unfunded mandate and the road does get
acted to the BL ramp money the town and
Nelson case involves route um Route 99
202 in Nelson back in the 90s the
department went in there reconstructed
it bypassed sections of Route 9202 that
are down by Granite Lake Area there and
um reclassified it to a class five town
of Nelson took the state to court and it
determined the the uh the Supreme Court
settled the question that it wasn't an
unfunded mandate so um with that that's
how we work our concern here would be
that if you take that Authority away
from the commissioner to
reclassify roads and I will say at the
seven years I was at the attorney I mean
seven years I've been with the
Department
um I I'm not aware that
reclassification occurring in that time
frame uh it's not something we do often
it's not something that's done it's only
it's typically done when these
when the these projects come in they
bypass a section of Road however there's
still Property Owners on that road
there's still residents on that road
that still need that road to access
their property there it takes on the uh
takes on the character of a local road
so I if this if this Authority was taken
away from the commissioner what you'd
end up with is little bits and sections
all around the state that are basically
local roads where where where the
department is going to be tasked with
their maintenance and uh you know
they're no longer part of the state
transportation system so again the
maintenance um priorities are going to
be those main roads so I'm happy to take
any questions that um any members of the
committee may have any questions
representative cluer okay thank you Mr
Leon do you remember the year of this
state supreme court decision about
involving the town I want to say it's
around 99 or 2000 I can uh if you'd like
I'm happy to to look that case up you
could and the committee any information
with the chair's permission I'd
appreciate it thank
you representative
Newman yes thank you Mr lebante I don't
believe I heard anything about the town
of Newington that was mentioned in
previous testimony I heard uh Nelson
barington do you hear have any
information about what yeah when we went
through and we did that that Turnpike
project there was a section of it uh I'm
looking back at my colleague that
Woodbury you said yes Woodbury Road in
that area and it was reclass it again
took on the nature of a um class a class
five highway so it was reclassified as
part of the
project to a class five Highway and
again that as it was testified to
earlier it was a around in the early
2000s when that
happened seeing no further questions
lante at this point in time we will
close the public hearing on house
question
conf
it being 10:30 I'd like to call to order
the public hearing on House Bill
578 and recognize representative Mooney
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
to you and good morning to members of
the House Public Works committee for the
record my name is representative Moren
Mooney of the town of miramac that's
Hillsboro County District number 12 I'm
here as a co-sponsor and in support of
passage on House Bill 578 an act
erecting a sound barrier along the F
Everett
Turnpike I'm here in place today of the
Prime sponsor representative Bill Boyd
of marac as he is ill today with the flu
however he has emailed to all of you his
testimony which I will read this morning
it's extraordinarily detailed and I know
he's done a lot of work on this
legislation so I'll read it to you at
this point coming from representative
Bill Boyd of
meramac good morning chairman Mills Vice
chairman Melvin and esteemed colleagues
of the public works and highways
committee I sincerely apologize to all
of you that I am not there to introduce
House Bill 578 as I AMR currently home
with the flu that hit me very late last
night House Bill 578 seeks to erect
sound barriers along the Northbound and
southbound corridors of the Fe Everett
Turnpike frequently known as feet Fe
T between Rayman wizor drive and exit 12
as the Department of Transportation
begins its widening of the
feet 17 neighborhoods and four
condominium complexes will be impacted
by the elevated noise debb that the
increased feet traffic will bring to
these
locations House Bill
578 seeks to protect Marx's quality of
life that will be affected once the feet
widening project is
completed you will hear testimony today
from my town manager Paul MC and Town
Council chairman Finley Roth house along
with my legislative colleagues speaking
about the increased feat noise that is
currently permeating these neighborhoods
and impacting the quality of life of the
people who reside in these
neighborhoods both Paul and Finley live
along the feet and can speak anecdotally
about the noise creep in their
respective neighborhoods It is believed
within my community that sound from feet
will only worsen upon its
completion as an offer of proof it is
generally accepted that an ambient noise
decibel level in excess of
66 DB that's an important number 66
DB is excessive and in need of abatement
there is a 29 nhdot environmental study
to which noise analysis was performed
and
identified
17 miramac neighborhoods along the feet
with decibel levels greater than
70 greater than the federal standards
70 but included only four neighborhoods
for noise mitigation within the scope of
the feat project that leaves 13
neighborhoods
uncovered NH Do's rationale for not
including these 13 neighborhoods into
the feat widening project ties into
their 2016 noise policy which factors
density into their sound barrier
criteria nhdot acknowledges that while
the ambient noise is excessive in these
neighborhoods noise abatement cannot be
provided because sound barrier
construction wouldn't reasonably Abate
the noise based upon the density
criteria within the nhdot t's noise
policy as such I respectfully disagree
with the hd's noise policy and their
assertion that neighborhood noise
abatements cannot be accomplished for
these 13 affected miramac
neighborhoods consequently House Bill
578 is a bill of action that will
provide noise relief to the
neighborhoods along the
feet in conclusion I urge favorable
support of House Bill 578 to quell the
noise creeping from the feet onto
maramax
neighborhoods to my esteemed colleagues
of the public works and highways
committee I thank you very much for your
time and attention and again that's
written testimony by representative Bill
Boyd of miramac a member of your
committee thank you Mr chairman and
thank you all for your attention we
would hope that you would recommend
thank you Miss Mooney and I understand
you have another bill to present
somewhere else so I'm going to forgo any
questions for you seeing as you
basically just had representative Boyd's
testimony so thank you for coming I
appreciate that Mr chairman being
sensitive of my time thank
good morning Mr chairman thank you thank
you for recognizing me next I appreciate
it it's a full day for all of
us full evening as well it's budget
budget committee day in marac I'm
Senator Tim MCU I represent District 11
which includes the communities of marac
Milford Amer and Wilton and I'm here
today on behalf of the residents of
marac in support of House Bill 57 8 if
it were only just the feet and the
pitter patter of little feet and not the
deafening Highway noise yes feet stands
for f ever Turnpike as I'm sure you all
know by
now but the only thing more deafening
than the highway noise are the calls and
emails that all of the legislators of
this District have been getting due to
the unexpected and yes I do say
unexpected I lived on back Rover Road at
one point and I can tell you we never
could have possibly predicted the
deafening level of noise and I lived on
the other
side at one point we could not have
possibly predicted I we did know of
course that eventually there would be
improvements to this infrastructure I
commuted South to Boston into Wakefield
Massachusetts and we knew that the route
three would be widened and someday
progress wouldn't be impeded but it
would it was most definitely impossible
to predict
the level of clear cutting right up to
the edge of the
property these individuals some were had
foresight sold their
properties moved away and were lucky
enough to get out from underneath their
Investments but I'm here for these
residents experiencing unexpected
impacts from the highway noise following
the recent Highway construction no one
could have expected what they are
enduring on a daily basis in their
backyards House Bill 578 seeks to
address these concerns by creating a
noise sound barrier going beyond the
typical guidelines so why should we do
that we do have guidelines these
guidelines have evolved over the years
they certainly are different than when
some of these longtime residents
properties so in standard Highway
projects as I'm sure you all know there
are usual formulas and measurements that
have served us well yet our current
situation does call for some flexibility
in protecting these communities from
this excessive
noise there are clear precedents that
exists in New Hampshire demonstrating a
commitment to address the community
cerns even when strict formulas fall
short for example during other budget
years yep it's a budget year I know in
2016 budget year the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation approved an
alternate design along the i93 quarter
near hookit another busy
Community another economic Hub community
members testing increased noise levels
in their neighborhoods spurred project
Engineers into developing a modified
noise barrier design they prior
prioritized like I'm asking you to do
they prioritized public well-being over
strict adherence to the standard
criteria in another instance in the 2018
budget year the dot teams in neighboring
counties adjusted noise barrier
parameters to manage unexpected noise
impacts from Highway expansion I'm
asking you to do the same
thing mayor M res residents face a
particularly challenging situation
recent Highway construction has
introduced a level of noise intrusion
unanticipated by traditional planning
models it disrupts their daily routines
they might be staying indoors right now
we all might be staying indoors when
it's Sub-Zero out but they want to go
outside and enjoy their fire pits mow
their lawns in peace plant their Gardens
and they can't do it homeowners that are
enduring this Sudden Change deserve the
special consideration that this
delegation is asking for they would like
you to help them preserve the quiet
enjoyment they've long expected and long
enjoyed I'm asking you to act outside
the norm in this
instance and recognize that rigid
adherence to the formulas sometimes
overlooks the human
element an element fueling Community
value and upholding property owner
rights listening to the residents
recount experiences of sleepest nights
drained relationships and declining
property Market values enforces the
urgency of this matter in communities
like ours noise is not merely a nuisance
it is a threat to the quality of life
and economic stability so if we rely on
past alternative approvals We Trust
local input we understand the immediate
and long-term consequences of increased
Highway noise we can together create a
solid foundation for you to vote House
Bill 578 ought to pass send it over to
me in the Senate and I'll take care of
it from there I hope I think I can do
that for you legislators should act now
to provide timely relief we hope that a
flexible approach in permitting noise
barriers will help protect residents and
preserve their property value even when
it's necessary to to depart from the
standard criteria and I realize that's a
tall ask but it's been done before not
once but at least twice in budget years
so I respectfully urge you Mr chairman
and your committee to support House Bill
578 and I thank representative Boyd and
my colleagues
from the marac delegation for bringing
this bill forward and I thank you for
your favorable support and I'm going to
defer questions to some of the experts
care I'd like to recognize
I microphone please I am sorry um what
in case you missed it it's always a
pleasure to be here um I am
representative Wendy Thomas and I
represent the town of marac I am in
support of House Bill
578 in the town of marac we understand
that the highway needs to be expanded we
understand the increased traffic in our
town and the headaches that go along
with it
we understand that this will require
patience on our part we get it but what
we don't understand is why our homes
where we live where we raise our
families are not being considered for
quality of life protections as a result
of this expansion especially when data
indicates that there is a direct impact
this bill makes sense go ahead and
expand the highway go ahead and do it we
agree with it but if it impacts the
residents quality of life please please
take care of them thank you very
much thank you any questions for
representative
Thomas seeing none thank
you I'd like to recognize representative
please and I assumed it was 578 cuz you
listed 5
68 got thank you welcome back to public
works good morning and thank you again
I'm Nancy Murphy representative of the
town of March um here to speak in favor
of HB
568 um HB 568 is a bill important to
Mary many Mary Mach residents whose
lives and peace have been negatively
impacted by the necessary expansion of
the fever turnpike I think we'd all
agree including the homeowners that have
been negatively impacted in the process
that the turnpike needed to be expanded
that said some residents have been
unfairly burdened by this expansion in
terms of increased road noise at all
times of the day and night they have
reported disruptions to their sleep
diminished ability to have conversations
outside and this is still winter
impacted View and exposure of their
homes to the roadway I'm here to support
impacted residents who seek a return to
the quality of life that will keep them
in New Hampshire the fef return Pike is
a thorough Affair for people from out of
state to visit and spend their tourism
dollars here in the granite state and
for New Hampshire citizens to travel far
and
wide Turnpike improvements however
should not come at the qual at the
expense of diminished quality of life
for residents among that along that
route though I understand that this
committee will be voting on the policy
of building sound barriers barriers and
not the fiscal note I recognize that
building sound barriers also comes at a
cost to the state if the state had
placed tolls at the border and along the
most highly traveled areas of the
turnpike many years ago the revenue
collected by user fees would have been
more than enough to cover the cost of
sound barriers along the highway where
they're necessary given the budget
challenges New Hampshire's facing taking
such action even today remind remains an
option for consideration to help fund
appropriate sound barriers for the area
identified HB 568 would help alleviate a
problem that we can and should solve on
behalf of our citizens I ask that you
support this bill so that Mary Mc
residents whose peace has been
interrupted can once again enjoy the
peace and comfort of their homes please
vote OTP thank you thank you any
questions for representative
Thomas representative Brown Mr chairman
uh someone indicated a little while ago
that they would be able to expand on
some of the issues in regard to let's
say the def decel levels and that type
of thing I don't know if uh this
representative has it information or who
would have that so that we can so we can
ask that question at sometime whether
that representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
being here today can you tell us a
little more about the barriers are they
wood and um
concrete hybrid design are they totally
wood uh how tall representative jur SL
interrupt you on this one uh that's
that's not her purview and that that
would be up to Dot and there there's
various types of barriers that that can
go up okay thank you thank you thank you
anything else seeing that thank you uh
and I would like to recognize
representative rang
back thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you committee um for the record
mining my name is representative
Rosemary rung I represent Hillsboro 12
which is the town of miramac and like my
colleagues have previously stated I get
a lot of calls from my neighbors in
miramac um regarding the sound and I my
home actually AB buts one of the
neighborhoods um Vista Way and Round
Tree which are listed in the bill and
this summer I happened to to walk down
the street and it was unbearable um I
know this is only antidotal but but I
would think that the measurements if
they were taken today would show a much
increased impact than when this project
was first um planned back in the um it
had to have been like 2014
2015 um and there are flaws in those
measurements um I think uh in in two two
sources I think are true one is that
with the clear cutting of trees that
have been done in in preparation for the
additional lanee um the sound has
increased substantially and I I suspect
that the role that trees plays in
dampening sound was
underestimated during the initial
measurements because without those trees
it's it's it's it's very loud also in
the measurements it assumes that people
are only entertaining or spending time
outdoors in their backyards many of
these homes face the highway and many
people entertain in their front yards
they may have porches or they may have
more property in their front yard where
they could put up a tent or a fire pit
or do
entertaining um but when I had a
conversation with someone who's working
on this project they said no we
calculate the impact point is on the
other side of the house and I don't
really believe that that should be true
many many people when they come and go
from their home they're they're entering
from their front door from the front of
the house to to get to their car so I I
really think that we need to examine how
we take those measurements and I think
um what I consider the flawed way is
what led to the decision that these
neighborhoods don't deserve to have
sound barriers and I want um there was
actually in the planning stages there
was a neighborhood um off of Clay Street
it it's um it's a little bit south of
the neighborhoods that are um identified
in this bill but they disagreed with the
measurement they hired their own sound
engineer who showed that it was
mismeasured and the state did add that
neighborhood to their plans and I really
don't think it should be up to um having
um people in a neighborhood having to
raise their own money to hire a sound
engineer to correct the measurement of
the state so that's another concern I
have and uh get to to represent of
jurist's point when he brought up the
whole issue of tolls the ever Turnpike
is a Turnpike it relies on user fees to
fund its maintenance repairs and any
capital
projects the first 21 miles of that
Turnpike has no user fees um from the
state line of Massachusetts up until the
Bedford tolls people use that that
Turnpike freely without contributing any
costs the busiest part of that Turnpike
is in Nashua where the where the state
has invested tens of millions of dollars
for a new bridge to Hudson for exit
ramps for increased lanes and there were
plans for a toll booth there and there's
even a tunnel that goes underneath the
turnpike to accommodate that and yet
that I don't know the history of that
but that was cancelled and the state so
the state did realize years ago that
they needed to charge user fees for to
the users and yet and with all due
respect to my colleagues from nashaa it
created such an unfair uh situation and
a great burden was placed on the people
of miramac for decades where they were
paying for all of that use from exit
ramp tolls so I would like to have the
committee um to support support this
bill 578 um and I think that in in the
future is particularly as you start
looking at the 10-year Transportation
plan to incorporate fairness in the way
that we fund our turnpikes they are
supposed to be self-funded but there
there is such an imbalance of Burden um
and if it was fair the the money to
erect these sound barriers would be able
to be covered easily with the that toll
Revenue so thank you very much I'd be
happy to answer any
questions thank you thank you any
questions representative
bogert thank you Mr chairman for
allowing me to ask my question and thank
you for taking my question if I
understood correctly and I could have
misinterpreted what you were saying uh
that where we collect in order to help
pay for some of this stuff because
that's outside of where the toll start
should we move the tolls closer to the
uh state line is that what's being
indicated so that we could gather the
funds to help pay for these sound
barriers I I agree um you know a
Turnpike is user fee funded and if I'm
going to use the turnpike
I I I would think that it's reasonable
that I should help pay for that I don't
believe people in the North country or
people on on the Sea Coast should pay
for a Turnpike because we've defined
that as a Turnpike it's not a state road
under do it's under the turnpike system
I believe it's fair to expect people
that are using it to pay for it and
that's why tolls were proposed at the
state line at exit I think it was around
Spit Brook Road um if you drive down
that way you can see that there were
toll boost plan the road is very wide
around there um people in the know know
about the tunnel um but it was cancelled
at the last minute um I don't like I
said I don't know the history of that
but that was a Fair Way of collecting
user fees from users to pay for what
using representative Melvin thank
takeing my question thank you for taking
my question could you tell me how many
residents that
affects oh in the neighborhoods outlined
here I don't have a specific number
thousands I would say and I also think
you know I know representative money
when she was sharing representative
Boyd's testimony they talked about the
density factor and um anecdotally I know
there are plans for some residents to
have accessory dwelling units an in-law
apartment something similar to that and
so I think if we're just looking at
single family homes that's not an
accurate reflection of density because
it may
underestimate the actual number of
residents that might be in a single
family home if you know what I
me thank you very
much okay thank you very
much I'd like to please recognize
representative Julie miles next please
welcome to public
works thank you very much Mr chairman
and thank you members of the committee
my name is representative Julie miles
and I represent the of marac uh in an
effort not to be redundant I will keep
this very brief um I am a legislator
committed to the well-being of our
constituents and I'm here to advocate
for the installation of sound barriers
along the Everett Turnpike in marac I
understand that previous assessments
concluded that marac didn't meet the
necessity criteria for the sound barrier
installation along that portion however
it's important to recognize that the
environmental conditions are not static
with ongoing development increasing
traffic volumes noise levels are likely
to rise potentially surpassing the
established thresholds in the very near
future proactively addressing this issue
now will prevent further degradation of
our residents quality of life it's also
worth noting that communities have been
granted sound barrier protection in
other similar
circumstances and for instance Bedford
just town the turnpike has been
benefited from some sound mitigation
measures to relieve its residents
distress the people of marac deserve the
same consideration they did not choose
to have the turnp turnpike widened
although yes it was necessary they did
not choose to have a major highway
expansion bringing traffic closer to
their homes but now they are living with
the consequences and one of those is the
lack of privacy as you're driving along
the highway now some of those homes you
can see directly into their window
by supporting House Bill 578 we can take
a proactive step to ensure marac
citizens are afforded the same
protections as those in neighboring
communities waiting for conditions to
further deteriorate before taking action
would be a disservice to the families
who have already endured this much I
urge the committee to consider the
involving environmental factors and
precedent set by other towns to support
be House Bill 578 for the well-being of
thank you for your testimony any
questions seeing
none I would like to
works thank you again Mr chair honorable
members thank you for letting me speak
to House Bill 578 as you know I am the
town manager of marac I have lived on
the F Turnpike for 31 years I bought my
home knowing the property backs into the
turnpike over the last 31 years the
noise coming from the P Pike has
increased whether it's trucks using J
brakes motorcycles racing up and down
the F Turnpike Public Safety Sirens or
just cars with high performance Ms the
noise has
increased I live about,
1500 feet from the turnpike I have
several Acres of woods in between me and
the
Turnpike my backyard now when I have my
dog out there I can not even hear her
sometimes barking because of the noise
on the turn
bike I want to make you aware that I am
not personally benefiting from this bill
that request of the sound barriers as
you have heard town of March has 17
neighborhoods along the F of Turnpike
with noise analysts of over 70 DB but
only four of those neighborhoods have
had sound barriers in included in the
scope of the project identified in the
2019 report Nash marac Beford
13761 final environmental
study vist way was identified as one of
those areas that was well above the
decel level for the sound barrier at 74
however Vista Way did not meet the
barrier area per benefited receptor s
square foot of less than 1500 ft benefit
household in order to meet the cost
Effectiveness criteria Vista Way was was
at
3,654 or 2.43 times higher than the
threshold requirements that was
established in 2016 before covid I do
have a couple
questions is this a Federal Regulation
for sound barriers or is it a state
standard why are we using standards
established prior to covid as we all
know the world has changed since Co in
closing I have had residents tell me
that when they're walking in the Vista
Way area they have to turn the volume up
on their phones all the way and still
cannot hear the music or ebooks in their
earbuds I believe that there is a
quality of life issue that should be
taken in account for these neighborhoods
I also believe the sound will only get
worse once the fever Turnpike is widened
and that tree buffer is diminished thank
you and if you have any questions I'd be
more than happy to try to answer
them thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you and
I would like to recognize the honorable
John
Graham welcome to Public Works sir long
see thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record um I am John Graham I live in
Bedford and I represented the Bedford in
the house for a couple of decades
and I was chairman of this
committee I can answer a couple of the
questions I'll tell you why the Nash
toll was never uh built when they when
they was planned it was taken out the
same way the marac tolls have been taken
down through legislative action the
deputy speaker at the time was from
nashor and she convinced everybody in
the house that it was a bad idea to put
him right on the border so that answered
that
question what I have passed
out is a bill that I submitted when I
was chairman of this committee to do
sound barriers along one neighborhood in
Bedford uh tber Lane it was not the
first time uh now Senator Murphy worked
on it for a couple of years when he
represented Bedford in the um house it
was found inexpedient to legislate over
VI rejections because of the density
policy so if you want to consider this
current
bill um in a favorable manner I ask that
you amend it to include tberry Lane and
I am sure that those on the Sea Coast
along the turnpike which is I95 the
Spalding and others would also like to
have sound barriers put up because they
have had separate bills in before to do
sound
barriers yeah it's going to be an
expense on the turnpike and I'll tell
you right now the turnpike is solvent
sort of
um and
um truth and lending I I'm chairman of a
special commission set up by the by this
um legislature the general court to look
at funding of our Highway fund and
Turnpike fund we are having meetings on
that um so it's a long-term
problem if you're going to do
anything you've got to include everybody
you can't just have separate bills for
separate
areas yeah um well I like to see T Lane
have uh their sound walls their decel
readings are higher than the ones that
are being reported from aramac so if
you're going to do that please do that
and remember that the turnpike system is
more than just the ever it is on the Sea
Coast as well um I think you all got a
briefing from dot on exactly what the
turnpike system was earlier
um last January uh so
please do what's right if you want to
turn this into a a committee to look at
what the policy is that's fine um but if
you order this out as ought to pass I
ask that it be ought to pass as amended
with not just tberry Lane but those um
areas on the other portion of the
turnpike over on the Sea Coast so that
we can find out what the true magnitude
of the problem is and I'll be TR I'll
try to answer any questions Mr
Graham seeing none thank you very much
welcome and last but not least I like to
Evans good
morning my name is John Evans I'm the uh
noise program manager for the Department
of Transportation I have uh spoken with
some of many of you in the past um and
I'm here to kind of provide a bit of
background and then uh possibly help
clarify some of the the comments or
questions that were brought up by the by
previous
testimony uh the Department of
Transportation uh as part of the uh the
the environmental review process for the
ever Turnpike Expansion Project did
complete a noise study for the entire uh
length of the of the Turnpike Expansion
Project between the towns of NASA and uh
Bedford so that includes marac as well
as any of the the Gap what we call the
Gap sections um where the the turnpike
has effectively already been widened uh
through prior uh prior projects uh that
uh that study identified 25 separate
locations uh in need of
potential uh evaluation for potential
noise impacts of those um there were
noise impacts identified in 20 separate
locations uh throughout the corridor uh
and barriers were uh and and noise there
were noise impacts uh identified at
approximately 289 properties throughout
the
corridor uh noise impacts as was stated
previously noise impacts are identified
as uh anything in excess of the the
Federal Highway noise abatement criteria
which in this case here uh is 66 DB the
reason 66 DB is used uh is because 66 DB
is the limit at which you know average
human speech um you know if if I'm
sitting having a conversation with you
uh face to face uh generally speaking
over an average hourly period 66 displ
would be the average over that period so
therefore noise levels in excess of 6 66
DB are considered to be an impact on on
the uh on on that area because the
ambient noise levels are louder and thus
it requires people to speak up to be
able to to have a
conversation um so when when the
Department of Transportation with our
when we do complete one of these noise
evaluations we identify noise impacts
then the next step is to identify if
there's potential abatement measures
which can be implemented
uh to help alleviate those noise
levels
um those typically come in the form of a
noise barrier or a burm you know amount
of dirt and the idea is being that if
you if you interrupt or place something
between the noise source and the area
you're trying to protect it will provide
uh noise reductions it will not
eliminate noise altogether it simply
reduces the amount of noise um the
in so the department completed that
noise noise assessment and uh I should
add too that um when we determine noise
impacts we actually U it's a common
misconception that we complete noise um
we complete noise measurements at each
individual home we do not and the main
reason being is because we're actually
required by the Federal Highway
Administration for federal aid projects
and then we our policy um in order to be
fair and Equitable follows the same
process for the turnpike system as well
is to is to evaluate noise impacts that
would result from the project using
traffic noise levels that would that are
20 years out into the future upon
completion of the project so in this
case here noise impacts were identified
using uh you under the build conditions
of the project using uh traffic volumes
that would that are anticipated to exist
in the year 2 44 so it's important to
note that some of the noise impacts that
were identified are those that which
have not yet been um been
experienced uh but nonetheless in order
to identify if we uh to identify that we
are properly identifying noise impacts
and and uh it environmental impacts we
evaluated impacts throughout the
throughout the entire Corridor under
those conditions we then all then can
utilize that the the noise modeling um
software which is which is used by all
50 states to identify noise impacts and
potential abatement measures um to to
identify where where noise barriers
would be both feasible and
reasonable the the policy requires us to
identify feasibility and reasonable
because we there are certain
circumstances where placing a noise
barrier may not uh either be feasible
from an engine engineering standpoint it
may not actually provide any benefits at
all or there may be some other uh say
environmental constraints or engineering
constraints that simply make it such
that you could not build a noise barrier
and provide any benefits and
reasonableness is and this is the one
that I think is is probably on was kind
of at the focus of prior testimony
relates to is it reasonable to build a
barrier some in some circumstances it uh
in order to build a noise barrier
uh you may need a very large barrier and
it'll provide very little benefits the
department obviously uh resources are
are um you know restricted and so these
noise barriers are extremely expensive
um they cost upwards of $100 per square
foot of surface area essentially and um
and so in order for us to ensure that we
we are providing noise barriers at uh at
locations that are going to provide the
most benefit we have what's called a
reasonableness criteria the reasonable
criteria
includes um a a calculation which
essentially when you put into the noise
model um you can you can figure out how
many square feet of barrier you would
need to provide noise reductions at
impacted properties and some properties
that may not be impacted but would still
be
benefited um would receive noise
reductions that's what a benefit is and
um if there are uh so so we we put those
into the model and the model can predict
what the noise levels would be with that
barrier and you you kind of play around
with the the height and the length and
you identify the optimal barrier that
would be the barrier that provides the
most benefit for the least amount of
barrier um because that'll be the most
effective barrier essentially the effect
the department has an Effectiveness
criteria of, 1500 squ feet per benefited
receptor receptor being in for
residential areas that would be uh a
single family home or uh multif family
home if you if you have a multif family
home say with a duplex with two two then
then that would represent two
receptors um so so you take that the the
square footage of the barrier divide
that by the number of benefits and that
gives you the square foot per benefiting
home and if that number exce exceeds
1500 square ft per Ben
receptor then it's considered to be uh
unreasonable and and a noise barrier
would not be constructed at that
location uh of within the the uh
Corridor of the N marac Bedford project
there were um a total of of 13 locations
which were identified as
um as as as require you know where we
have identified potential noise
abatement measures of those only seven
were found to be feasible and
reasonable all of those were as a result
of the um the the the effectiveness
criteria not being met uh and and that
is the case for Round Tree uh Round Tree
the Round Tree neighborhood as well as
the Back River Road neighborhood and and
again the main reason being there's not
we're not getting enough benefits to
provide uh to provide a barrier that's
considered reasonable in accordance with
the Department's noise policy I would
add that the Department's noise policy
that reasonableness criteria is required
by by all 50 states to have a
reasonableness criteria the department
does get to set that and the Departments
uh We've we've reviewed that in relation
to the other states and we're we're in
the the half of states that are
uh
generally more barrier friendly on
construction there are other states that
have a much higher reasonableness
criteria and therefore more barrier
barriers are less likely to be
constructed in those States uh States
like Vermont and Maine are are among
those that have much higher requirements
and then there are other states say uh
like Maryland or uh uh Virginia and
whatnot that may have they that may have
provide more uh may have reasonableness
criterias that are lower and thus are
more likely to be um to to provide noise
abatement and again the the Department
of Transportation here in the state of
New Hampshire we're we're we're in the
middle of the road if not leaning
towards uh states that are that are more
commonly thought of as as being uh
states that that do pro allow for
barrier construction when when it's
reasonable um so uh but I I would note
that of again there were there were 20
locations that were reviewed with noise
impacts and um and there were
various uh noise abatement measures that
were identified but again only seven of
those were identified as feasible and
uh those those seven locations alone are
going to require approximately $20
million $19 million uh to be in which
has been included and will be
constructed as part of this project if
we were to implement uh noise barriers
at the other remaining locations to be
uh that are that are impacted it would
require uh
another
um an additional $24 million within just
this Corridor to uh to construct those
those additional noise barriers that do
not meet the department uh Department's
feasibility and reasonableness
criteria um so with that I'm sure that
there's probably some questions and I'd
love to answer them uh and you know I
know I know everybody's time is valuable
so I'd like to open that
up thank you Mr representative Jack uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
appearing uh we've heard several times
that we ought to adopt a policy that
we're going to throw away the density
criteria and just build them wherever
people think they need them what would
Federal Highway say if we did first of
all these are these standards are
Federal Highway standards not made up by
the do and what would they say if we
started to do that so uh it's important
to note that for this is this project is
a uh Turnpike funded project so in this
case here we don't need Federal approval
for for those types of projects on the
turnpike system but what we've tried
what we have done in order to be
Equitable across the entire
Transportation network of the State of
New Hampshire is we've applied the same
policy that is required of the federal
federal government of Federal Highway
Administration uh AC to to the our
entire system of roadways regardless of
whether or not they're Turnpike funded
or uh federally funded in the case of If
This Were A Federal Road uh and we did
not have a noise
abatement criteria you know that that
reasonableness criteria we would not get
an approved noise uh policy and that
means we would not be able to construct
any projects uh on the on the federal
system within the state of New
Hampshire using federal dollars further
questions representative
brow thank you Mr chairman I have a
number of questions but if you could
just go back to what you just said about
if we exceed the benefit basically of
what we've agreed to the 1500 criteria Y
what was that reasoning we would not get
federal funds to do any other noise
abatement projects in the state is that
said so what you're saying is so
essentially what you're you're asking is
if we didn't have a Reas a
reasonableness having a reasonableness
criteria is required of us in the
Federal Regulations our noise policy
must adhere to all the requirements of
the federal
requirements um if our noise policy
doesn't comp comp with the requirements
within that within the Federal
Regulations then uh we would not have an
approved noise policy and we would not
be able to seek environmental approvals
to to construct any projects on the on
the federal system within the state of
New Hampshire so effectively what that
means is we would not be able to accept
federal dollars to construct any road
project within the state of New
Hampshire until we we had a project that
demonstrated compliance with the Federal
regul ation which includes compliance
with the Department's noise
policy
followup so um in this uh I think it was
a 1500 number that that you referred to
correct and some states have a lesser
requirement some states have a higher
requirement so does that fall within the
federal guidelines in other words do
they say, 1500 or 1,200 or a th000 does
that make any difference yes so they
they just indicate that it needs to be
we need to have some way of fair and
equitably identifying
reasonableness um and and they say that
it needs to be either based upon a uh
cost per square foot or a or a square
foot per benefited receptor if you look
at our past noise policies we used to
have noise policies that had um that had
utilize a cost per square foot um and
the problem with us utilizing a cost per
square foot is cost as everybody knows
you know you have inflation and and and
you know and cost of construction go up
you're constantly having to re-evaluate
the cost but then at the same time you
end up uh increasing the uh the
the the cost per square foot number to
to to adjust so essentially if you do
the math it comes back it has always the
Department's uh Effectiveness criteria
has always been, 1500 square fet per
benefited receptor if that makes sense
Mr chairman if I might I have two very
short questions very short please so in
regard to the criteria that uh the other
Representatives spoke about um that uh
since the trees have been cleared
basically that the noise levels have
gone up significantly so have those uh
sound decel levels been verified since
the trees have been cleared so that it
would potentially impact this
significantly so again uh we utilize a
noise model to identify noise impacts
and we're using uh using it under the
instructed conditions now in order to be
sure that we've identified any potential
noise impacts and the and truly
identified the benefits of noise
barriers we actually typically the the
the noise model is um you we can add
noise uh what we call sound zones and in
this case here like like tree zones or
say a row of buildings or something like
that can actually be added into the
noise model but as a rule of thought and
for this project we we we did not model
with any trees at all so what that
effectively means is regardless of
removing those trees or not we're
getting noise levels that that are as
though there were no trees there to
begin with and there would no be no
trees there to end with great um so so
essentially it's identifying all
potential noise impacts that are that
would be within that Corridor okay and
then the final question so I those
decibel reports available to the public
for them to view based on your 1500
criteria to show for instance that these
neighborhoods have, 1500 these other
ones have 1,400 or whatever show the
discrepancy and and where those would be
so that uh if if there was some concern
that might be a neighborhood right next
to another one that uh maybe that
barrier should be continued just in that
area to also continue with that
abatement so the so so as part of the
environmental process for the
environmental revieww process for the
ever Turnpike project uh we completed an
environmental study uh of the entire
Corridor that that study includes the
results of the noise noise analysis that
was completed for this project uh so
which highlights all of those things
you're asking for thank you very much Mr
thank you Mr chairman for your tolerance
representative fauler for the final
question thank you Mr CH
uh do you have the flexibility to offer
something is it all or nothing barrier
or nothing or can you offer noise
mitigation measures that are short of
providing a
full noise barrier such as triple
glazing windows or Stockade fences or
things like that uh so so so the answer
is is is effectively no um we if you're
if you're providing noise abatement it
needs to provide noise benefits um we
also do not uh and the Federal Highway
Administration requires that that when
you mitigate for noise in residential
areas it's for exterior areas only so
windows and those kinds of things would
not be uh something that would be
potential noise abatement for a
residential area um there's we do get a
lot of questions for say the
installation of privacy fences I know
one of the uh one of the forers the
speakers that spoke earlier did mention
privacy fences privacy fences uh do not
provide noise uh benefits they're not
noise mitigation
sometimes they're installed in areas
where say there are property impacts or
something that that are causing you know
the property impacts physical property
impacts to that property say we're
putting in a uh some type of a water
quality treatment you know Basin or
something like that there they' removed
a bunch of trees that were providing
privacy or something like that that's
that's kind of dealt with on a Case by
case basis property by property based
you know upon RightWay discussions you
know in the in during that process but
but generally speaking uh we do not
provide wholesale uh you know
uh privacy privacy fences and there's
certainly not intended to be any type of
noise
mitigation thank you for the information
Mr Evans I'm sure we're going to invite
you back when we exec this bill so that
you can answer any and all and how many
hours worth of questions we might have
I'm happy to to to come and speak for at
many hours if you if you wish I'm sure
you will thank you this time I close the
578 and moving right along quickly
trying to catch up to our schedule I'm
going to open a public hearing on House
Bill 713 relative to mile markers along
Route
112 uh thank you Mr chairman uh I'm
proud to uh introduce house bill 73 in
relation to mile markers along Route 112
my name is Jerry Stringham I am the
representative from the towns of Lincoln
Woodstock Easton and Livermore uh
Livermore uh is 97% federal land uh it's
the largest physical town in my district
and has no voters but what it does have
is uh Route 112 the Canam Mangus Highway
which I think most of you U probably
have driven on at some point uh the
Canam Mangus highway is 36 Mi long it's
a beautiful uh Road it's uh uh the part
of the road that we're talking about
here as as Lincoln and Woodstock uh in
the western part and the southern part
of the towns of Conway uh in the eastern
part uh the road itself is a National
Treasure and a destination many times of
year particularly uh during the leaf
changing uh uh season
uh when when uh uh new englanders and
those from other parts of the country
flock uh to see our our our Beauty at
its glorious uh it's a very windy road
with constant turns and
Hills uh it's a destination for uh
sightseers um uh hikers uh and campers
uh it in it includes such uh such uh
destinations as Lincoln Woods uh with fr
conia Falls sabad day Falls uh some of
our 4,000 Footers including the Hancock
Mountains and the OAS and has more than
a dozen uh campgrounds along it um uh so
you know while we bring here there are
safety issues uh with this road there's
basically no cell phone service uh along
most of Route 112 in that section so and
people do get in trouble the roads are
very very hilly there's a hair pin turn
the grades are 9% and up uh and um uh
you know should something happen like a
breakdown or or an accident or uh when
the weather's bad even sling sliding off
the road uh there's no direct ability to
ask for help so typically what happens
when a car or bicyclist or truck gets
into trouble uh a Good Samaritan offers
to help and uh uh uh of course they
can't can't call either so they proceed
down the road until their cell service
uh kicks back in and by the time they've
getting there they may have driven 5 to
10 miles cu the the stretch of road with
with little cell service is over 20 mil
long along that road uh and uh at that
point the details get a little foggier
sometimes and it's hard to hard to relay
what's going on so House Bill 7113 SE to
better the odds uh that our neighbors
and visitors will get timely help in the
uh unfortunate
circumstances uh that occur uh very very
frequently uh along this highway and it
does it does so uh by putting mile
markers up there so that when somebody
notices trouble they have more of an
ability to relay what's going on there's
one time you're going to going to notice
the mile markers is it's when you're
driving away from something and you're
trying to uh make a mental note of of of
where the help is needed uh three
different organizations have asked for
this bill uh uh the Lincoln Police uh
who are here and will will uh can speak
about uh circumstances that they've
they've F uh fallen into will be here uh
the Lynnwood Ambulance Service uh which
is called on dispatches uh and um uh you
know one of the things they mentioned is
it can even be harder in busy times
because uh not not only do you not know
where to go but uh there can be some
pretty heavy slow traffic so uh it can
make a big difference on uh on uh how
how long they can respond and then
finally the EM emergency vehicle
services are towing companies uh and
Arnold's Towing I know was uh was hoping
to be here today but uh they responded
to three calls last night between 1 p.m.
and 5:00 a.m. uh you know up up uh
toward Franconia Notch and so on so uh
and um but they did want me to mention
that they emphasized that people have
especially people who who don't drive
the can very often have a great deal of
difficulty of describing where it is
that they noticed a breakdown or
somebody in
trouble uh um you know separately uh
uh like to mention that some of the
service organizations basically uh the
Rotary Club in Lincoln uh on the west
side and the rotary's Conway office uh
con Conway uh uh Rotary Club a both have
mentioned that um this is something that
they'd like to see and be willing to
help if it helps uh reduce the cost it's
certainly not something uh this is a
major public safety and it should be
done right and engine engineered
properly it's not something uh that uh a
service organization can do the entire
amount but uh for example one thing
mentioned in the budget is that there's
a uh uh
$65,000 of traffic control uh presumably
when the 36 or so mile M Signs would be
uh put up um who's going to make sure
that the cars stop at the appropriate
time uh both these organizations clean
clean the can uh at least once a year so
they block off uh they have big signs at
each end of the can you know be be
careful and uh you can find pictures of
people like myself with with big yellow
vests on and uh pick picking up loose
trash and um you know making this kind
of a permanent um Improvement to the
public safety for those who come to our
towns uh you know would be certainly
something that might help reduce the
overall cost of this although I think
you know primarily here we're going to
be talking about just the advisability
of it and and hopefully getting your
support So in summary you know the Can
is a beautiful iconic Highway that draws
visitors and out ofers to our towns and
our restaurants and our hotels and uh I
hope you'll uh uh support House Bill 713
and send it over to the finance
committee where where I serve so thank
you for your time if you have any
questions I'd be glad to answer thank
you do we have any
questions representative Brown I just
have a quick question this I spend a lot
of time up there hiking and taking
friends that visit from out of state up
there all the time so uh in the winter
up there those uh snow banks are pretty
high I know you stick up the tree
branches up there to enable the plows do
that so these are going to have to be
specially constructed road marker signs
I assume taller than normal
yeah I don't know if this I mean the
banks are pretty high along i93 too yeah
uh um you know there's there's you know
I think one of the factors is you know
how they should be designed how can we
make them blend with the natural beauty
of the highway and you know not just be
uh you know big and ugly I guess uh but
uh you know what is the right height um
uh you know there's there was talk about
having a contest maybe they should be
silhouetted and look like the old man in
the mountain or a bear rather than just
a uh rectangular green sign with a
number on them but uh um but the the
issue that you brought up is why uh why
this can't be or why it be better done
by the professionals at Dot and the
involved with the design rather than
just the charity thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much representative
uh I would like to recognize Deputy
police chief Scott McKinley who's asked
for 20 minutes and I don't think we'll
need you more than three
hopefully good morning um the reason why
I put 20 is I have no idea I saw you had
a question mark there and I was like
what kind of questions are going to be
asked um so welcome to Public Works sir
well this is my first uh Adventure down
here doing something like this in 34
years in law enforcement um I spent a
lot of time in Lincoln this is my second
stint um back in the
90s um believe it or not we had the same
issue that we had no mile markers or
anything to help visitors not only the
ones in our our own State the New
England area in our own country but
visitors from throughout the world who
come and visit our lovely Community um
we have an incident up on on the can
they have a hard time telling us where
it is so by the time we get our
apparatus up there police Fire EMS it
may not even be in our jurisdiction so
now what we've done is we've moved our
emergency services to a desolate part of
our community and then we get another
call so now we're coming back because we
don't have the proper
information to put people out there I
started this issue um with the state
I've actually reached out to
uh William Lambert who was the traffic
engineer administrator for New Hampshire
dot back in
2022 and I was told unfortunately
there's no money so I sent another email
in
2023 same response
2024 same response and I reached out
with Linda massima and I asked her for
some
assistance and she said she was going to
work on it she did not get
reelected and then just
recently uh representative Stringham had
advised that he had put forth a bill
which I
150%
support um I believe that we need this
in our community and this affects
112 all the way from Bath New Hampshire
all the way over to Conway there are no
mile
markers on that roadway whatsoever it's
a safety issue
so that's kind of why we're here
um he talked about the cell service
there is none as you know anybody that's
spent time up in that area um and we
just want to be able to send the
services responsibly to where they need
to be um
without uh
jeopardizing responding to other
thank you very much for your testimony
Chief any questions representative
fauler thank you Mr uh in your
experience as the for service department
of Agriculture been aware of this issue
or involved in this uh question at all
I'm I have brought this up to our local
law enforcement um representatives for
the forest service and
they I got some push back saying that it
would uh
unbuy the roadway um which I totally
understand um the can is a beautiful
area but it's a very unsafe area at
times when we have emergency situations
um my chief just indicated to me that I
failed to mention that we have issues
with radios as well so when we get out
on the can uh sometimes we can't even
communicate to our own dispatch
um we have to relay our conversations
through another fire apparatus or
emergency vehicle that might be coming
to where we are and then they forward it
to our dispatch we dispatch at Lincoln
Police Department Lynwood
ambulance uh the fire
department we also call out for services
for towing Etc um and we also assist
with uh communic ation with the US
Forest Service as well um we work very
well
together thank you
representative
bogert thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um I'm not sure but was it true at one
time the the kangamangus during the
winter was not uh cleaned up or anything
it was left kind of like closed
due to the Natural
uh I don't know when that was I believe
it was in maybe the
40s it was they closed it because they
were having issues with cleaning um the
only Road that's closed in that area
would be uh be Notch Road um so in
reference to that that do does a
wonderful job the snow banks are
extremely high as he's saying they're
probably sometimes seven or8 feet tall
um but I think if we work together as a
team we can make sure that those mile
markers stay unobstructed so people will
have a reference point that they can
emergency thank representative
Newman I I hope this is a a brief
question if there's no cell service and
no mile markers currently how do people
that have had a
situation get any get through to
you sometimes they describe they'll say
you know by that big rock or by the
hiking area on the on the sharp sharp
corner we know that's The Hairpin um a
lot of times it's a guessing game um
we'll head out there we'll send a police
unit and we'll go up to that uh location
trying to confirm that there's an issue
um I've gone all the way over
to um past sabad Day falls where we stop
um patrolling we we cover Livermore all
the way to sabay and I've not found a
crash that they reported because it it
actually happened five miles further
towards the Conway side so this is a
delay in in getting Emergency Services
where they need to be which we all know
that every
second that we Del lay an ambulance
could cost somebody their life and that
is the biggest reason why I'm very
passionate about this and I will push
and push and push until I retire to get
mile markers out on that
roadway thank you very much yes one
followup please yes but how do they get
in touch with you to tell you it's by a
big rock they don't get Self Service
until Lon
mountain or there's this one little tiny
spot up by CL Graham that sometimes if
you stand in the right location and hold
your phone up that you might be able to
get a message out to somebody so you
know we're hoping with technology we
have some you know we have a lot lot of
things moving forward technology wise
that make this easier possibly with GPS
but we need to do the responsible thing
as a state and and explore this and and
get some mile markers out there so we
can get Services where they need to be
understood thank you very
much uh one question Mr Melvin
representative Melvin could you could
you tell me how many uh service calls
you get out there
year well I had my dispatch supervisor
pull up um our statistics and I will
tell you
that because we go out there for all
sorts of different things we Patrol it
on
average on average at 300 plus calls per
year
um and and those are you know responses
to a crash uh somebody calling in a
reckless driver um somebody parked in
the wrong space I mean it's it's medical
call
it just it would I could break it down
if I need to come back and speak some
more and talk hours I can do that
too thank you very
much at this time I would like to call
barones thank you sir welcome to Public
Works
thank you it seems like this was just
last Tuesday I'll for you uh so thank
you members of committee uh I appreciate
the opportunity my name is Lee bonis I'm
the administrator of the Bureau of
traffic at Dot and State traffic
engineer uh among other things Bureau of
traffic is responsible for signs and
that's why I'm here to speak to you
today um the department does not take
any position on this bill but I'm here
to provide some basic information and to
answer questions from the perspective of
do
um I will try to be brief recognizing
the time um just for so we're all in the
same language mile markers sometimes
called mile posts um our prevailing
Authority on this matter is the manual
of uniform traffic control devices
published by USD and is applicable to
all public roadways that manual um calls
them reference location signs uh or
enhanced reference location signs but
I'll call them m markers for for
convenience um these signs uh I think we
all are familiar with them they display
the miles from the origin originating
point of the route the enhanced signs
also include a root shield and the
cardinal direction north south east west
uh for the purpose of this it would say
112 with the shield with North uh east
or west on it and it would have the
mileage from the origin in bath um the
purpose is to assist a motorist knowing
how far they've traveled and the
distance to the exitor destination
that's the primary purpose according to
Federal Highway Administration it's also
useful as reference for engineering and
maintenance so we know where we're going
to dig out a culvert or what have you
but most importantly is for Public
Safety identifies location of an
incident for cers reporting an incident
and for responders to find that
incident uh so the existing landscape uh
New Hampshire has a mix of mile markers
on roads uh interstates and major
divided highways uh we've been
transitioning to the enhanced reference
location sign this is the required sign
that you see um on um say in estate 93
393 right here in the concerete area um
we just had a recent project to update
those signs um on all but um a few of
the interstates some are Turnpike um and
Spalding um haven't haven't had an
upgrade as yet but they're being done as
projects allow U but we handled 9 3 393
293 um and 101 with all new signs um so
that's the current
standard um there are other roads uh on
the national highway system uh both
divided and undivided that have a mix of
older style signs uh ones that aren't
necessarily compliant with the current
rules um you'll see some smaller units
say Mile and sometimes you'll see even
small smaller ones that have uh
intermediate
markings um they're they're everywhere
but they're not everywhere um and um
they're they're out there but they are
not no longer compliant
um mile markers are required uh to be EV
at every mile according to the manual
uniform traffic control devices um but
they do allow intermediate signs here in
New Hampshire and and uh nearby States
we use two10 of a mile as our intervals
uh and so that's what you'll see on the
interstate um the advantage of them at
closer intervals is if you have to walk
to find the nearest sign you're not
walking a full mile you're walking at
most two two t0 of a mile uh on the
interstates with open um sight lines you
can sometimes see from one to another uh
even at night and on the interstates
we've got them back to back on both
sides of the highway when it's divided
uh so you can see the nearest one may be
behind
you uh let's see our Focus has been on
the higher volume roadways uh where
where the value of them does the most
good for the most people uh but they
also provide values on all roadways and
as we've heard from testimony here
particularly on roads with few other
landmarks and identifiers um so I am uh
I am personally an advocate for mile
markers um I think that they uh they do
provide a lot of value um let's see uh
the legislation uh the proposed
legislation
specifies uh mile markers at one mile
intervals along the full length of New
Hampshire 112 also known as can mangas
highway from Lincoln to
Conway um and the intended benefit is
principally for Public Safety um some
key notes um New Hampshire 112 runs from
Bath to Conway um the legislation kind
of mixes things says full length of 112
but also says linol to Conway for the
assumptions uh for the fiscal note uh I
referred to lincol to Conway um and to
be a little more specific I assume the
start in Lincoln would be at the uh
White Mountain National Forest boundary
uh going east to uh Route 16 in
Conway um it did specify one mile
interval
uh we recommend 2/10 of a mile but the
fiscal note is uh based on one uh one
mile um but I also included I'm not sure
if it got into what you saw um an
estimate for at
210 um we also assume the signs will
comply with the uh mutcd uh which will
be the same size as on the divided
highways uh we're assuming only on one
side of the road um because it is a
two-way Road um and that they would have
backtack signs so that each each
Direction can see the signs One
Direction you'll be on the right the
other direction will be on the
left so that was the those were the
assumptions um so basically advantages
like like I said I'm an advocate for
mile markers u i I could I wish I could
spend my retirement putting mile markers
up around the state uh there's plenty of
work to do um the addition of mile
markers would um well we've we've heard
that testimony there's there's a lot of
advantages to it in addition to um you
know for engineering and maintenance um
so the other folks uh non-emergency
folks have references uh we do recommend
the two uh 02 mile interval uh some of
the drawbacks and unfortunately I always
have to talk about things like that um
the project uh there's only so much
money and this project would displace uh
money from other projects that are
already programmed uh through the the
established prioritization project um
another drawback is impact on Scenic
Vistas unfortunately we can't uh change
the face of the signs they are required
to be that way just like a stop sign has
to be red eight-sided U and so forth um
our reference location signs have to
meet these
criteria um and the other I I guess the
the biggest drawback is uh is kind of a
a fairness thing is there's an expect
there's an expectation of similar signs
on other roads
um uh you know this is proposed for the
Canam Mangus uh we've got lots of other
roads that could also use them us3
Lancaster to Pittsburgh uh route n Kean
to hopkington uh 26 C Brook to Errol uh
25c Pont to Warren uh 16 Bartlett to
gorm it goes you know goes on and on uh
also New Hampshire 112 from Lincoln East
to Bath
um we like every thing there's a lot of
things we want to do and there's only so
much we can do with the money that we
have so we have a prioritization uh
process through the gaset um and so
that's really my my concern
is legislating the priorities when
there's already an established priority
um however I do feel that that strongly
that they provide value this is
certainly an eligible Road and would be
worthy um and then then I'll have to
deal with the the next town that comes
and says what about our road so any
questions representative Jack uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you for appearing
uh what's the funding source for this
road and the second question would be
does the mutcd have any May or shall or
or language that would would guide us as
to whether these should be installed
okay uh funding is um normally we would
take Federal funding when we can take it
um this would be eligible for federal
funding one way or another um we do have
a constrained program and so if you take
federal funds for this it's less federal
funds for a bridge or a you know
sidewalk or something else um we could
also use State funds if we we've had
earmark funds for projects before um we
certainly don't turn down any source of
funds um as long as it's legitimate um
but for the for the Assumption we were
assuming it was federal funds uh as far
as um Maze and shells and the regulation
uh you are not required to have mile
markers uh however if you do they are
required to be either of the form that's
called a reference location sign or the
enhanced reference location sign um and
those are the the green and white um the
the simpler ones just say mile and then
have an uh mile number in vertical uh on
the side of the road um we you we have
used the enhanced on the interstates
because it helps folks know what road
they're on it also helps reinforce which
direction you're going in because you
see North or east you know every two10
of a mile uh so our preference our
recommendation is to use the enhanced
SS any further
questions representative bogert
could you uh provide a best guess
estimate of what the cost of this would
be it's it's in the it's in the fiscal
note yeah and just so you don't have to
look it up we had roughly 288,000 would
be at the one mile interval and about
580,000 uh for them at 210 of a
mile thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your test Tony sir and at this
point in time I'd like to close the
713 which brings us to opening up the
hearing for House Bill
745 naming a bridge in the city of Keane
after Charles
Redfern and I would like to recognize
welcome to Public Works
sir thank you Mr chair this is my first
bill to come before this committee so I
thank you for having me and thank you to
all the members of the committee it's
it's great to be here my name is Philip
Jones representative New Hampshire state
representative chesher district 3 I'm
also in my 28th year as a city councelor
in Kean and I'm also on the board of
directors of Pathways for keing a
nonprofit organization
I'm here today to talk to you
uh about RSA 3 colon 43 uh name which
deals with naming a state facility uh
I'm requesting an alternative use Trail
bridge in Keen New Hampshire be named
The Charles Redford Bridge um it's a
340t span it was uh proposed in 2015
finished in 2018 it was done completely
by the state of New Hampshire and for
that I thank you
us this uh since it's completion this
bridge has seen thousands of Walkers
bikers snowmobilers horseback Riders and
so on uh in Kean we have a great
system of of bridges and alternative use
paths and we're very proud of that there
and the reason I'm telling you this is
because we're going to tell you a little
Redfern our system is very well planned
use trail system when it comes to
discussion about planning the developing
of the Keen trail system Charles Redfern
is the Mr Everything 30 years ago
Charles Redfern had a vision for a trail
system using mostly former rail beds at
that time the city father said show me
he was a founding charter member of a
nonprofit organization which he called
Pathways for Keen the organization's
sole purpose was to raise money to pay
for the development and maintenance of
the entire city alternative use Trail
Network thanks to Pathways for Keen
mostly through the dedicated tedious
work of Charles Redford millions of
dollars were raised via private donation
to fund this well-planned extension
extensive trail system without the
vision the tenacity and a dedicated
efforts of Charles Redford there would
Kean this bridge is on the south side of
keen so we we never gave it a name it
was the only bridge on the South Side so
we called it the South Bridge and we
just referred to that uh coming up
within the next few four years there's
going to be three more bridges coming up
on the south side of Keane so it loses
that Geographic
significance uh that that we have uh one
of us we're reusing if any of you from
the London dery area the prous bridge we
bought that for a dollar if we didn't
pay that yet uh my wife gave me a dollar
today I'll give it to you and we would
uh so there goes that South that
designation is Southbridge so it's a
bridge with no name right now uh Charles
Redfern has done everything he could for
our trails with in New
Hampshire uh right now he is in uh
Florida preparing to sell his property
down air because he's trying to prepare
for some uh health issues coming up
which I really don't want to get into uh
I would like to see this bridge named
after Charles I know uh some past
practices is that the person had had to
be not living anymore uh I would like to
see I know that's not in the RSA and
would like to see uh this happen I think
it would be great if he could take he
has a um a grandson who's handicapped
who uh he Charles and his wife have have
refurbished a van so it's can use
handicap facilities
and they take this grandson everywhere I
think it would be great if Charles could
take his grandson push his him in his
wheelchair over that bridge and say yes
they named this after me and not have to
one day push his grandson over that
bridge and say your grandfather's gone
but uh we would like to but that was
Bridge was named after
him Charles Redfern does not even know
that I'm here today he doesn't know how
to know about this bill right now um I
know this is a public process but we
were just trying to keep it a surprise
as much as we
could and that being said I know of you
receive
Communications from the Keen city
manager the Keane city
mayor a number of uh Keane City
councilors someone from the Board of
Education uh people from the pathways
for Keen uh people from the bicycle
pedestrian advisory committee everyone
in the community is in full support of
this um I would have liked to uh have a
letter from the full city council but
that would have been public publicly not
notified and then Mr red would have
found out about this uh and would have
ruined the surprise I would rather wait
till after you executive this bill
before he even knows about
this I would gladly entertain any
questions Mr
chair I'm sorry any questions
representative fuler yes thank you
representative Jones could you describe
a little bit more about Red's history I
know he was uh he has a career working
for the state as former city counselor
um few other things other than just as
Mike Path
experience thank you for that question
it's a very good one and uh actually he
worked for the uh New Hampshire
Department of Revenue as an auditor and
he brought in millions of dollars to the
state so would this would help be a
payback for him yeah uh he did he was on
the city council uh and I served with
him
uh and he's not a political guy he's
kind of apolitical but he did that
because he wanted to see some of these
trails get passed through uh the the
city council level and he did a great
that any further
questions saying none thank you for your
testimony sir thank you Mr chair I would
like to recognize Edward hos
please introduce yourself please and uh
welcome to public
works thank you Mr chair um I'm Edward
hos I'm from Kean I also serve as a city
councelor uh along with my colleague uh
representative Jones um The Charles Red
Fern has a long history in New Hampshire
as um rep Jones uh referred to as an
auditor uh that was his career he is
retired from that now um at the same
time he picked up the Reigns in in Keen
uh serving as city counselor he
continues to serve on our B Le
pedestrian advisory committee so he's he
he and it's rare is a city meeting that
he's not there um the uh the background
of all of us you'll recall we're all
used to having rail Trails today uh that
are converted and now there's different
fundraising that how they get maintained
and how they're brought along um that
but we all know the benefit of having
abandoned Railways converted into
recreational use um when uh Charles
Redfern started this work there was no
such thing it was only less than 20
years prior to when he started this work
that the rails were still active in Keen
so the rails went out of business in
Keen sometime in the 70s and all of
these uh Rail lines lay fallow and
eventually would have been carved up
into different uh divisions into
different um uh commercial occupancies
residential occupancies whatever but all
the properties would have been cared up
but he saw this opportunity right out of
the box back I think it was over 30
years ago um and as was described he uh
went to the city city said you hey it's
not for us to do you do it and he did he
went right out and started pounding a
pavement and he continues to do that in
support of the trail so we know the how
the trails have evolved over the years
right now this Trail this bridge is a
key connector uh from Walpole and
farther north all the way down through
Keen Swansea and down into um Winchester
eventually down into uh Massachusetts as
well uh the trails are a true uh Revenue
driver for the city and um and they are
maintained as such through the efforts
of fellows like Mr red fern with the
pathway for Keen uh program and
continual fundraising he also supports
the other groups that use these chairs
not only cyclists and pedestrians but
the snowmobile uh organizations are are
very key in uh supporting and
maintaining these Trails um just as uh
reper Jones referred to um Mr red fern
is is is suffering some some illnesses
and um we we'd love to have this on his
uh on his desk before um as soon as
possible um and he still is going to be
fundraising he's out there all the time
he's helping make these things continue
and be of value no one deserves this
more than Charles Chuck
Redfern thank you thank you I I have a
question you said you're a city
counselor sir yes okay and you we don't
have a letter yet as of yet and I
understand why uh but did did I
understand somebody has from the city
the city manager or something has sent
us testimony I I
understand I have verbal information
that uh the C the city manager the city
mayor uh various members of the bicycle
pedestrian uh committee um various me
members of some neighborhood groups that
I'm affiliated with um there there is no
one if asked that would not support this
this move this change this naming thank
you the the letter has been brought to
my attention which which letter is that
uh City AEM
from we have this KH the mayor okay
that's that's good enough for us that's
one of our one of our
requirements
okay thank you thank you uh thank you
sir for your
testimony and at this point in time I
would like
to recognize Mr John Hayes please come
forward state your name for the record
and uh welcome to public
works thank you Mr chairman my name is
John Hayes I'm a res I've been a
resident of Keane for about 25 years and
I'm a longtime user of the
U the multi-use trails I'll call them
the bike trails in
Keen um Charles Charles I'll call Chuck
Redfern has worked tires tirelessly to
develop and improve the multi-use trails
in and around
Keane well he served as a city counselor
for many years his amateur well I'll
call it amateur career because He Did It
For the Love of
it for as a bike trail Advocate started
well before his days as a city counselor
and Contin continued well after
it I first met chck Chuck while we both
worked as for the Department of Revenue
Administration and we commuted together
while we uh between keen and
conquered and he convinced me to serve
on the bicycle pedestrian advisory
committee a committee that advised City
Council on bike path issues as well
as as well as uh Pathways for Keen
501c3 uh that raises money for bike path
projects and currently the man manano
rail trail
Consortium was through my work on all
these uh different organizations that I
got to see how hard Chuck Works uh for
Kean and the Region's bike path system
he is Relentless in trying to accomplish
the next goal for completing the next
project he is always the number one
fundraiser he's always skilled at the
politics of building bike trails and he
was always respectful of other uh
stakeholders points of view and always
always Prov included them in into
decision
making in short if if you name any
segment of the of the rail trail system
in Kean Chuck Redfern had a hand in
bringing it to
fruition Keen Keane is very lucky that
Chuck Redfern chose to devote his life
to bike trail advocacy because without
without him Keen would not have been
able to build such a comprehensive and
beautiful bike path system so I'm
definitely in favor of naming the bridge
over
101112 that Charles
Redfern uh Charles Redfern
bridge and certainly if any questions
I'd be happy to answer them do we have
any questions this time seeing none
thank you very much for your testimony
and I would like to close the public
hearing on House
uh we got a couple of other housekeeping
items to go here and but for right now
I'd like to uh have a brief five minute
Republican caucus in the back office
please and
uh the Democrats are welcome to a little
five minute back bathroom break or
another
CAU
e
I'm
here Tuesdays and Wednesdays anymore
just as Wednesdays Thursdays we have
sessions is it's Mondays or Fridays what
Tuesday and recognize representative
Jack from motion uh thank you Mr
chairman I move retain on House Bill
100 have a motion to retain and seconded
if I could just raise one more Point uh
the fact last La when during the hearing
we learned that there are outstanding
loans from the revolving Loan Fund uh
and this bill could very well throw a
wrench into those they they there there
are loans both to the Conway cic
outstanding seeing no further questions
I'm going to ask the clerk to call the
rooll
please thank you Mr chairman again uh
said yes oh okay Mike's on please
representative
bogur yes yes representative B
yes representative Brown
yeses Lewis is not here represent sud is
not representative cler yes clerk votes
yes representative Edgar I
representative funner yes representative
Newman yes representative alone yes
representative jurus yes representative
rockmore
yes Mr chairman chairman votes yes the
vote is 15 to
zero 15 Z thank you very
much now like to open the executive
session on House Bill 745 naming a
bridge in the city of Kean after Charles
Redburn and recognize represent pres
uh I recommend
OTP do I have a
second representative fauler seconds
open this for discussion I'll start out
by saying it was recognized normally
just as a as a matter of of uh president
on this committee we wait until somebody
is deceived
before we try to name after anything
after him or we'd be deluged with these
kind of bills uh however there has been
president before uh at least twice that
I know in this committee uh
representative was wzor was one of them
in Manchester and I forget the
gentleman's name up north Ray Burton Ray
Burton we named something after him for
for the same reasons as as this
committee is pushing this bill forward
um that and the fact that normally we
always insist on having a letter from
the town and it sounded like they had to
be a little secretive about this
however representative Edgar found the
letter from the mayor so that's that's
good enough for for me as far as I'm
concerned having that I'll repres
recognize representative Jack uh thank
you uh we also uh did this for Ruth
living repr sen fauler one of the pieces
information that representative Jones
said
he got to mention is that the Redford
name is well known in Kean he was former
president of keing State
College and uh this bridge is located on
both ends of it are on keing state or
adjacent to keing State Property so uh
it you know everybody knows the honory
here in town I think it's a very
appropriate um very appropriate
designation given the given his history
his
career and in the use of the bridge
thank
you any other comments excuse me Mr
chair yes
represent represent faor referred to Leo
Redfern Charles's father and Leo Redfern
was my College president during my
college career at Keen State and retired
the year I graduated and later on they
named The Performing Arts Center at Kean
for him the Redford Center so this is a
great compliment uh to the recognition
of not only Leo but now his son Charles
thank
you any further questions or comments
seeing none I will ask the clerk to call
roll this is onot to pass representative
Melvin I representative folie hi
representative kazinski
yes representative
bogert yes representative B yes
representative Brown yes represent
reprentative
cluder uh yes clier votes yes
representative Edgar I representative
fauler yes rep representative Newman yes
representative alone yes representative
chus yes representative rockmore yes and
Mr chairman chair votes yes the vote is
15 to
zero the executive session is closed
excuse Mr chairman consent we want to
put on consent or I wanted to inquire
about to the gentleman first okay sure
okay thank you okay I'm going to close
the executive session on House Bill
745 uh gentlemen we can put this on a
consent calendar where it will
just you know be brought up at the
consent Vote or if you would if you'd
like to attend we can have it put on the
regular calendar and he can be in the
audience and we'll try and special order
to the beginning of the session thank
you Mr chair uh I don't know if he'll be
back from Florida at the time but if we
do uh if we do put it do it from the
floor I know there's people from Keen
that would want to be be there in
attendance but if you if it's easier for
you to put it on the consent agenda
that's fine with
normally Yeah well yeah but we usually
have uh we usually have enough for the
House vote but you that's correct we can
always have them there for the Senate
votes too so I think we so consent would
be fine consent would be fine yes do we
have any objections to put it on the
consent calendar from anyone no let's
put it on the consent calendar thank
you um I think that's all I had like I
said I'm going to schedule next Tuesday
starting at at 10: to exec and once
again my intention is to get us out
around lunchtime so I'm going to
schedule these execs
for 15
minutes each and we'll be out of here by
noon
again well one after the other one after
the other I can I could time them yeah
put them all at the same time Joe you're
on the hook for
the report yeah thank you Joe Joe's
doing the clear
Charlie did you call him Joe I I might
have Joe Melvin was one of my managers
right yes and you are going to have
you're going to write a uh this one this
one a little blur for
clips there being no uh
further business y'all can go home I
guess unless you want to hang around and
talk Mr chair good job again to but we